no tengo miedo me siento tranquilo
caminando hacia el punto de control
pasaré iré a casa porque sé que estoy en
lo correcto
esas fueron las palabras del opositor
ruso alexéi navalni cuando se dirigía al
control de pasaportes del aeropuerto de
moscú justamente allí fue detenido así
él no se rehúsa a ir con ustedes quiere
con su abogada lo están deteniendo pero
yo tengo todos los documentos que
ustedes necesitan la orden de la corte
la orden del servicio de prisión federal
y todos los archivos les conviene
dejarme ir con esos years read guys
era la primera vez que el líder opositor
pisaba suelo ruso en casi cinco meses
procedía de alemania donde fue
trasladado el 22 de agosto en estado de
coma luego de haber sido envenenado en
la ciudad de tomsk las autoridades
resaltaron que la detención de naval ni
se produce por haber incumplido las
condiciones de una pena de cárcel
suspendida de tres años y cinco meses
que fue dictada en 2014 por malversación
de fondos el servicio federal
penitenciario ha pedido a la justicia
rusa que reordene su ingreso a prisión
la detención ha sido condenada por
organismos internacionales el presidente
del consejo europeos jean michel indicó
que es inaceptable y pidió la ley
oración inmediata el gobierno
estadounidense se unió al llamado al
igual que la administración del
presidente electo joe biden el señor
naval ni debería ser liberado
inmediatamente y los responsables del
inadmisible ataque contra su vida deben
rendir cuentas los ataques del kremlin
al señor naval ni no sólo son una
violación de derechos humanos sino una
afrenta al pueblo ruso que quiere que se
escuchen sus voces francia italia
polonia y lituania se han unido al
llamado a que una valley sea liberado de
inmediato amnistía internacional aseguró
que se trata de una detención injusta
que se da por ejercer activismo político
pacífico y libertad de expresión